REPUBLIC.
A BIG PORTION OF THE SPEECH,
MAYBE THE MAJORITY OF THE SPEECH
DEVOTED TO THAT VERY SUBJECT.
I'M BACK WITH A PANEL OF EXPERTS
TO DISCUSS THIS.
KAITLIN COLLINS FIRST TO YOU.
THIS WAS A COMBATIVE SPEECH AND
NOT AT ALL SUBTLE.
>> A VERY POLITICAL SPEECH.
I THINK WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
THE SPEECH THAT HE GAVE ON THE
ANNIVERSARY OF JANUARY 6th AT
THE CAPITOL, THIS MIGHT BE THE
MOST POLITICAL, MOST FORCEFUL
SPEECH IN THAT SENSE THAT HE HAS
GIVEN SINCE TAKING OFFICE.
IT'S A BIT OF A SURPRISE,
BECAUSE WE HAD SPOKEN TO WHITE
HOUSE OFFICIALS EARLIER.
WE ASKED, HE IS SOMEONE WHO
STRAYED FROM NAMING TRUMP VERY
MANY TIMES DURING HIS FIRST YEAR
IN OFFICE.
HE OFTEN STAYED AWAY FROM THAT.
SO AS A WHITE HOUSE REPORTER TO
HEAR HIM COME OUT SO QUICKLY AND
NAME DROP HIM SO FAST AND TALK
ABOUT BASICALLY THE BRAND OF
EXTREMISM THAT HE THINKS TRUMP
HAS FOUNDED WITHIN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND CLEARLY HE
THINKS IS THRIVING NOT IN THE
SENSE THAT HE WANTS IT TO, HE
CAME OUT VERY QUICKLY AND SAID
TRUMP AND SAID MAGA TIME AND
TIME AGAIN.
IT WAS A VERY POLITICAL ATTACK
AGAINST THOSE REPUBLICANS.
HE TRIED VERY HARD TO DRAW A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN REPUBLICANS
AND REPUBLICANS WHO STYLE
THEMSELVES AFTER DONALD TRUMP.
OF COURSE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
TAKE THAT DISTINCTION REMAINS TO
BE SEEN.
A VERY POLITICAL SPEECH BY
PRESIDENT BIDEN AS THIS
BASICALLY FULL FRONTAL ATTACK ON
WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE HAS BRANDED
MAGA REPUBLICANS.
>> AN ATTACK ON MAGA
REPUBLICANS, EVAN, AND A DEFENSE
AS HE PUT IT OF DEMOCRACY.
HE LITERALLY FRAMED THIS AS A
BATTLE BETWEEN LIGHT AND
DARKNESS.
>> YEAH, LOOK, IT'S CLEAR THIS
IS A SPEECH JOE BIDEN HAS WANTED
TO GIVE FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
FOR THE LAST 18 MONTHS HE HAS
NEEDED TO LEGISLATE.
HE'S NEEDED TO OPERATE WITHIN
THE BOUNDARIES OF WHAT
WASHINGTON WOULD PERMIT.
BUT THERE HAS BEEN A GROWING
SENSE IN HIS MIND THAT ACTUALLY
THE THREAT IS MUCH GRAVER THAN
JUST A POLITICAL PROBLEM.
AS HE SAID TONIGHT, A REALLY
MEMORABLE MOMENT WAS TOO MUCH OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THIS COUNTRY
IS NOT NORMAL.
HE'S APPEALING TO WHAT HE
BELIEVES WHAT A LOT OF AMERICANS
FEEL WITH PLAYING FOOTSIE WITH
POLITICAL VIOLENCE OR THROWING
OUT A FREE AND FAIR ELECTION.
HE SAID I KNOW I'M DRAWING LINES
HERE BUT I THINK A LOT OF
AMERICANS WILL BE ON THE SIDE OF
THE LINE THAT I DRAW.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT ONE OF THE
LINES THAT HE'S DRAWING.
THE PRESIDENT DID STEP UP HIS
CRITICISM OF MAGA REPUBLICANS
DIRECTLY.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> DONALD TRUMP AND THE MAGA
REPUBLICANS REPRESENT AN
EXTREMISM THAT THREATENS THE
VERY FOUNDATIONS OF OUR
REPUBLIC.
NOW, I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR,
VERY CLEAR UP FRONT.
NOT EVERY REPUBLICAN, NOT EVEN
THE MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS ARE
MAGA REPUBLICANS.
NOT EVERY REPUBLICAN EMBRACES
THEIR EXTREME IDEOLOGY.
I KNOW, BECAUSE I'VE BEEN ABLE
TO WORK WITH THESE MAINSTREAM
REPUBLICANS.
BUT THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY TODAY IS
DOMINATED, DRIVEN AND
INTIMIDATED BY DONALD TRUMP AND
THE MAGA REPUBLICANS.
AND THAT IS A THREAT TO THIS
COUNTRY.
>> ALL RIGHT, SCOTT, THERE WAS A
LOT IN THAT EXCERPT TO DISSECT
REALLY.
HE SAYS NOT ALL REPUBLICANS,
MAYBE NOT EVEN A MAJORITY ARE
MAGA REPUBLICANS.
HE TALKED ABOUT HOW HE CAN WORK
WITH SOME REPUBLICANS.
HOW WILL THIS LAND?
>> YEAH, BUT THERE'S NOT A
SINGLE REPUBLICAN IN THE COUNTRY
HE'S ENDORSING FOR ELECTION OR
RE-ELECTION.
I MEAN HE'S NOT GOING TO GO OUT
AND CAMPAIGN FOR REPUBLICANS
THAT HE LIKES IN THEIR SENATE
RACES OR IN THEIR HOUSE RACES.
THIS WAS A VERY, VERY PARTISAN
SPEECH.
HIS CORE MESSAGE TO ME WAS IF
YOU DON'T VOTE DEMOCRAT, WE
DON'T HAVE A DEMOCRACY ANYMORE
SO THAT'S NOT GOING TO LAND VERY
WELL AT ALL WITH ANY REPUBLICAN
VOTER, NO MATTER WHAT KIND OF
REPUBLICAN THEY CONSIDER.
AS I WAS LISTENING TO THIS, IT
SOUNDED LIKE A CONVENTION SPEECH
TO ME.
THERE'S A LOT OF POLLING OUT
THERE THAT SHOW A MAJORITY OF
DEMOCRATS DO NOT WANT HIM TO RUN
FOR RE-ELECTION.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS CANDIDLY LESS
ABOUT THE MIDTERMS AND MORE
ABOUT CONVINCING DEMOCRATS THAT
HE'S UP FOR A RE-ELECTION
CAMPAIGN.
ONE FINAL TACTICAL THING.
I DO THINK IT'S SMART FOR THEM
TO TRY TO PUT TRUMP AT THE
CENTER OF POLITICS RIGHT NOW.
IF REPUBLICANS CAN STAY FOCUSED
ON ISSUES, THEY'LL DO BETTER.
IF THEY STAY FOCUSED ON TRUMP,
THEY'LL DO WORSE.
>> IT WAS RIGHT AWAY.
HE MENTIONED DONALD TRUMP'S NAME
RIGHT AWAY.
>> WITHIN MINUTES.
>> AND FRAMED THE WHOLE SPEECH
AROUND THAT.
EVA, YOU HEAR THIS TALK ABOUT
THIS BEING A POLITICAL SPEECH,
AND I DON'T THINK YOU COULD
IGNORE ANY OF THE REFERENCES TO
MAGA REPUBLICANS THERE.
BUT FOR SUPPORTERS OF JOE BIDEN,
FOR SOME OF THE VOTERS THAT
YOU'VE BEEN SPEAKING TO OUT ON
THE TRAIL THERE, IF YOU DO
BELIEVE THAT DEMOCRACY, SMALL D,
DEMOCRACY IS AT STAKE, IS THIS
THE TYPE OF DEFENSE THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN WANTING TO HEAR?
>> ABSOLUTELY WITHOUT A DOUBT.
AND SOMETHING ELSE THAT REALLY
STUCK OUT TO ME IS THAT HE
ALMOST SEEMED TO BE RECLAIMING
PATRIOTISM.
OFTEN YOU HEAR REPUBLICANS ARGUE
THAT THEY ARE THE PRO AMERICA
PARTY.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOT PATRIOTIC
ENOUGH.
BUT WHAT WAS MORE PRO USA THAN
THIS SPEECH?
AND I THINK THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS WANTED TO
HEAR.
WE HONOR THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE,
RIGHT?
A NOD TO OUR DEMOCRACY BUT ALSO
A NOD TO PRESERVING REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS.
HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF ALL
AMERICA.
YOU MENTIONED BEFORE TOO MUCH OF
WHAT IS HAPPENING IS NOT NORMAL
IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE ARE STILL AT OUR CORE A
DEMOCRACY.
I MEAN ALL OF THESE THINGS, IT
WAS A VERY, VERY PATRIOTIC
SPEECH AND I THINK THAT THAT IS
A LOT OF WHAT DEMOCRATIC VOTERS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, THEY WANT TO
BE PATRIOTIC TOO.
THEY WANT TO BE PART OF THE
AMERICAN STORY TOO.
I THINK HE SPOKE TO THAT.
>> HE MADE A DIRECT PLEA TO HAVE
VIOLENCE OUT OF POLITICS.
THERE IS NO PLACE FOR VIOLENCE
IN POLITICS HE SAYS.
HE REFERENCED THE FACT THAT YOU
CAN'T BE AN INSURRECTIONIST AND
BE FOR DEMOCRACY.
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND TO AN EXTENT ARE
CAUGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS, IS
THIS SOMETHING THEY WANT TO
HEAR.
>> NO QUESTION.
NO QUESTION.
PEOPLE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
PEOPLE WITHIN I THINK GOVERNMENT
MORE BROADLY WANT TO HEAR
NATIONAL POLITICAL FIGURES, TO
INCLUDE OF COURSE THE PRESIDENT,
TO COME OUT AND ABSOLUTELY CALL
OUT POLITICAL VIOLENCE,
EVERYTHING FROM LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARD OFFICIALS TO LOCAL
ELECTION OFFICIALS TO OUR -- MY
OWN FORMER COLLEAGUES AT THE
FBI.
NO PLACE IN OUR COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW.
THEY SENSE VERY PERSONALLY AND
DAILY THE RISING TIDE OF THREATS
THAT THEY FACE.
AND I THINK THOSE THINGS WILL BE
TAKEN POSITIVELY.
ON THE OTHER HAND, I THINK
PEOPLE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE SEEN A
BIT MORE REFERENCES TO
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THERE REALLY WASN'T MUCH TALK
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING ABOUT
THOSE INSURRECTIONISTS, HE WAS
MERELY CALLING OUT THE FACT TH